In the last lesson, we talked informally
about what it meant to be computable.
But what does it mean to be computable?
What even is a computer?
What kind of problems can we solve on
a computer, or problems can't be solved?
To answer these questions,
we need a model of computation.
There are many, many ways we could
define a notion of computability.
Ideally, something simple and
easy to describe, yet powerful enough so
this model can capture everything any
computer can do now or in the future.
Luckily, one of the very first
mathematical models of a computer
serves us quite well,
a model developed by Alan Turing.
In the 1930's decades before we
had digital computers, Turing
developed a simple model that captured
the thinking process of a mathematician.
This model which we now call the Turing
machine is an extremely simple device
and yet completely captures
our notion of computability.
In this lesson,
we'll define a Turing machine.
What it means for the machine
to compute and either accept or
reject a given input.
In future lessons,
we use this model to give specific
problems that we cannot solve and more.